hey what's up guys my name is eciano
welcome back to my ray tracing series
lighting lighting and shading everyone's
always talking about lighting and
shading i mean when i think of good
graphics or photo realistic graphics and
rendering the first thing i think of is
lighting lighting shading you know
shadows ambient occlusion global
illumination like sure the quality of
the actual geometry and the textures
they matter a lot as well but lighting
that's really what it's all about isn't
it why is that the reason why lighting
is so important is because it's
literally how like vision works if there
was no light anywhere we wouldn't
actually see anything because what we
perceive with our eyes is a result of
light rays actually hitting us i mean
you don't even necessarily need to think
about the human eye let's take a camera
for example when we point and shoot a
camera at something the sensor inside
this camera the actual sensor that is
the thing that is soaking in all of the
light that's hitting it if there's no
light hitting the sensor
when i see anything there is no image
and the way that the camera works is
actually surprisingly similar to how
we're going to make our ray tracing code
work so more on this later in the series
because lighting is such an important
topic we will be spending a lot of this
series talking about different lighting
algorithms and different kind of ways
for us to to simulate but also somewhat
approximate and manage this kind of
concept of simulating light rays hitting
our actual viewport and i'm completely
serious when i say that's a complicated
topic i mentioned this book in the very
first episode of this series physically
based rendering from theory to
implementation this book is like filled
with this kind of stuff because it's
extremely complicated there's a lot to
it today we're going to start our
lighting journey but don't worry it's
going to be extremely simple in the
beginning and eventually it's going to
lead us into actual photorealistic
rendering which is very very exciting so
without further ado
let's begin now in the last episode of
this series in the visualization episode
we actually went a little bit further
than we'd already gone in episode three
with our current code base we took a
look at how to actually solve these
kinds of ray sphere intersections to
actually fully see where in 3d space our
hit point was and we even applied a
little bit of lighting to it i highly
recommend that everyone watches that
video because i think that kind of
visualization really helps to provide
you with a deeper understanding of how
ray tracing actually works and
understanding is very very important for
this kind of stuff so there is going to
be a little bit of overlap from the kind
of code that we typed out last episode
in c sharp using hazel and also here
inside our c plus plus project now the
current stage that we are at is this
pink sphere we haven't really adjusted
it for aspect ratio as you can see but
that's okay next episode we're going to
talk a lot more deeply about the camera
but for today the best thing i can
recommend is kind of trying to make this
viewport like square we could of course
do this programmatically but we're not
going to bother since that's not going
to really apply for future episodes that
way you'll kind of see what's going on
here now you may have noticed that my
render time has increased slightly from
the last episode or from episode three
the reason being is i'm on this laptop
which is not as powerful as the computer
that i use so no no code has actually
changed we haven't made anything slower
we're just simply running this in
release mode but this kind of rendering
time indicator is just a a good kind of
measure of what is actually going on and
if we're doing stuff that significantly
slows down our code so if we hop on over
into our per-pixel function that
contains the actual math as being
executed over here we've solved this
quadratic formula discriminant that we
learned about in the second episode and
we'll be referring to more of this like
episode two math here in this video as
well and because we know over here that
if our discriminant results in a value
greater than zero we have two solutions
if it's zero then we have one solution
if it's less than zero so if it's
negative we have zero solutions using
that we're able to conditionally return
a different color so we return pink if
it's greater than or equal to zero and
of course just black if it's not now if
these quadratic equations aren't really
quite making sense to you and you would
like to revise your math a little bit
more then i highly recommend you take a
look at brilliant the sponsor of this
video simply put brilliant is my
favorite place to learn math on the
entire internet they are an absolutely
fantastic resource they're a website
filled with courses on various stem
topics and unlike other course websites
brilliant strong points are the fact
that they are extremely engaging and
interactive classes they don't just sit
you down and throw content at you hoping
that you'll absorb it they actually get
you to engage and interact with the
content as well as quiz you on what
you've learned to make sure that you're
actually retaining that information and
learning we're learning all about ray
tracing here we're learning how to
render photorealistic graphics that
involves a lot of math and it's also
extremely visual lots of math extremely
visual
that's what brilliant is all about their
math courses do a fantastic job of
covering literally everything we'll be
using inside this series and they've
also got various other stem topics such
as computer science and data structures
the best thing about brilliant is that
you can get started for free just click
my link in the description below but
also brilliant have been nice enough to
offer the first 200 of my subscribers
who clicked that link in the description
below 20 off an annual membership as i
mentioned the key to this series is
understanding making sure that you
understand everything and so if you're
struggling with the math at all or you
would just like to understand it more
comprehensively then brilliant is your
friend huge thank you to brilliant as
always for sponsoring this video so
ultimately the plan for today
is to continue solving the quadratic
formula we've worked out the
discriminant which is this part over
here that's listed as 32 here we just
need to then square root it and then
work out the two solutions by adding or
subtracting negative b from it dividing
by two a
and then we'll get hopefully our two
intersection points now of course if the
discriminant is zero then we'll get the
square root of zero which is just zero
so we'll get plus minus zero which is
the same as just not having that at all
obviously it doesn't matter if we
subtract zero or add zero we'll still
only have one solution therefore we have
that kind of if it's zero we have one
solution section in which case t will
technically be the same if our code will
compute two values as we'll get it to
the two values will just be the same now
we are still outputting our color as
just kind of an rgba one byte per
channel format that's going to be fine
for now we'll have to write a little
conversion function because ultimately i
want to move into dealing with floats
for our color values just like we would
be doing if we were using gpu shaders
now just because we're going to be using
floats for colors doesn't mean that we
can't use this kind of 8-bit per channel
approach we can it's just that our float
value will ultimately just result in a
number in an integer between 0 and 255
which is obviously the maximum kind of
range we can display with just one byte
of data so the first thing i want to do
is kind of rephrase this or replace this
to actually return a glm vect4 so if we
go back to our header file i'm going to
do the same thing this per pixel
function now is going to return a glm
vect4 which is going to be four floats
so if we want pink we'll return one zero
one one so rgba just the green channel
here is going to be zero and if we want
black we're going to return zero zero
zero one now you may have noticed here
that the previous value of black was
actually this right so we had kind of
the alpha first that's because the alpha
channel occupied like the most
significant bits of this actual integer
we have to remember that because it
means that when we do this conversion
we'll have to shift it up to the most
significant bits which means we'll have
to shift it left by 24 places to get
that bit or those bits into the right
place inside this memory but it makes
more sense to us if we just define the
alpha channel being here so that it
reads rgba now if we come back over here
into our render function now this per
pixel function obviously isn't working
because this buffer is still a un-32t so
this is exactly where we have to do our
kind of conversion so what i'll do is
separate this a little bit i'll have our
glm vect4 color over here that's going
to be our per pixel and then i'm going
to write some kind of like convert to
rgba function that will take in our
color and output just a um32t let's go
ahead and scroll up a little bit i'm
just going to make a little namespace
called utils for all of these various
utilities we might have and that's where
i'm going to implement this convert to
rgba function now i don't really need to
copy all those floats so i'll pass them
in as a const reference here and now we
can get started so first of all let's
just convert a single channel so for
example the red channel to convert that
we just need to multiply it by 255
f because what that's going to do is
when color is one which is the seemingly
the maximum here it's going to make this
exactly 255 which is our maximum and
when it's zero it's going to make it
zero now what if it's above that well
yes technically we will get a value
above that which will probably spill out
into other channels depending on how we
actually write this code what we
technically should do is make sure that
that value is clamped between zero and
one meaning it's no less than zero and
it's no greater than one if we were
running this code on the gpu using an
api such as vulcan or directx or opengl
it would actually be doing that clamping
for us depending on what image format
we're using here of course we're doing
everything ourselves there is no like
graphics pipeline there are no gpu
drivers doing all this extra stuff for
us it's just c plus code so we have to
handle that ourselves what i'll actually
do is i'll scroll down over here and
before i actually
provide this convert to rgba function
with the color i'm just going to set the
color to be glm clamp color and then i
want to provide it with the minimum
which will just be glm vect40 and the
maximum which is going to be glm vector
1 this will clamp every single component
of that vector to be between 0 and 1. so
now we can be sure here that it is in
fact never going to be 1.5 or negative
0.5 or anything like that so once we're
multiplying it by 255
we now need to convert it into some kind
of integer because well that's not going
to be useful to us at all so what we can
do is just convert it into a unit 8t
that will be our red channel and there
we have it we have a one byte unsigned
integer type here that is now going to
contain a value between zero and 255.
let's go ahead and do this for all of
the other channels now i didn't really
mention this about glm but one of the
nice things about their api is that you
don't have to write like xyz you can
just write rgb it's referencing the
exact same memory it's just a different
name it's like an alias that you can use
just like in the shading languages so
now that we have all of these let's
combine them into a un-32t
which is what i'm going to return over
here so we'll type in un-32t
result and that is going to be the a
channel remember that's the first one
that we needed to shift up 24 places so
we'll say a shift left 24. that's going
to put it into that most significant
byte of that un-32t then we're going to
combine it so we'll use a bitwise or to
grab the blue channel and shift it up 16
places then we'll do the same with the
green channel but eight places and
finally we'll have the red channel at
the end occupying the least significant
bits and finally we can return our
result so there you go you could do all
of this on one line of course i've just
written it out so that it's hopefully
more readable now let's go back over
here and add that utils namespace and
there we go that hopefully should work
so let's run this code just to make sure
that it's working remember the big
change that we've made here is that
we've switched up our code in the per
pixel function to actually use vect4s
instead of un32ts and there we go we
still see a pink sphere now it's
important to test and make sure that our
color channels are in the right order so
i'm going to make it a red sphere
hopefully so this is blue we know that
we've flipped our red and blue channels
but there you go it's red so that is in
fact correct okay awesome so now we can
use floats to express colors just like
we would be doing if we were programming
on the gpu in shaders which is exactly
what i want the main reason why i wanted
to do this so early on as well is just
because dealing with colors in floats is
something that i want you to get used to
first of all if you're not already but
also because dealing with colors as
floats is just much more comfortable
it's a lot easier to do common things
for example if you want to do like some
gamma correction that's all going to
work as you would probably expect
because it's in a zero to one range if
you square a value that's like 10 you're
gonna get a hundred it's not exactly
what we're looking for so my point is
just that if the colors are between 0
and 1 a lot of the math that we actually
want to do to calculate those colors
they actually work really well with a
number between 0 and 1. so it's really
useful to get into that habit as soon as
possible really okay so let's talk about
how we can actually solve the rest of
the quadratic formula well we know it's
going to be minus b negative b plus
minus the square root of the
discriminant which we already have so
let's write that part down so the rest
of this is going to be minus b plus
minus the square root of that
discriminant and all of that is going to
be divided by 2a so divided by 2a and we
need to make sure that we're obviously
dividing all of this so that is that is
the rest of the code that we effectively
need to type out here now this part is
not useless though because this lets us
effectively early out from all of this
we don't need to continue solving the
rest of this and actually running this
code evaluating this mathematical
expression if there are no solutions
because our rage is completely missed
our sphere so we can just return well
you know like the clear color in this
case but it could be just an indication
that like hey keep going ray like you
didn't you haven't hit anything so what
we'll actually do is flip this around so
that if the discriminant is less than
zero then let's return black which is
going to be like our clear color
otherwise we're going to keep going and
actually calculate a color so for now
let's define some kind of sphere color
i'm just going to make it a vec3 we
don't really care about the alpha at
this point in time i'll still keep it as
pink for now just to make sure
everything's still working like it was
and obviously if i just return this now
as is i'll have to make sure that i'm
adding in that alpha value as well but
at the moment the kind of non-modified
sphere color if i run this code i should
get exactly the same result as before
i've just kind of flipped the way that
we deal with this if statement here so
we've got our terms abc we literally
just need to plug them into this
equation and that's it now because we
have a plus minus though we know there's
going to be effectively two outcomes to
this and either one of them are
solutions we can find out which one is
the closest hit if we want to but
ultimately they're both going to give us
solutions so let's go ahead and type in
t0 that's going to be our kind of plus
variant so minus b plus glm square root
of the discriminant divided by
2 times a let's go ahead and surround
this with parentheses so that it's clear
what our division is doing and that is
in fact t0 now t1 the other solution is
going to be minus b minus square root of
the discriminant divided by 2a that's
kind of it let's go ahead and drop this
comment down here and we've got our two
t values
now going back to the math episode we
know that these t values are not some
kind of coordinate in 2d or 3d space no
instead what it is is basically a hit
distance that we can then plug into our
original ray equation which was a plus
bt so a and b a is the ray origin b is
the ray direction and t is what we've
just solved for and as you can see over
here we can do this if we want per
component so we only had x and y we did
this in 2d space on paper but we now
have a z component we can just calculate
it for a z component as well because our
array origin and right direction will
also have a z component so this will all
work and once we have that it will
provide us with an actual 3d coordinate
for each component that we have
so since we will have an x y z we
effectively have three of these
equations that involve t so we plug t
into all three and we get an xyz hit
position that's our coordinate in 3d
space which defines where our sphere was
actually hit so back in our code we have
ray origin we have ray direction and we
have t now there's no reason for us to
actually do this per component we don't
have to do float x and type in like ray
origin dot x
plus
ray direction dot x times t 0 or t 1 we
could do this that would work however
because of the way the glm's api works
and in general the way these math
libraries work this isn't unique to glm
is we can just do this same operation to
all three components at once by just
writing ray origin plus ray direction
times t0 which of course is very useful
so we have our first hit position i'll
say h0 and then we have our other hit
position which is going to be this t1
here so this is our sphere potentially
getting hit twice once on the entry and
once on the exit with this ray so if we
actually wanted to visualize this in
some way
which hit point would we use well if we
take a look at this we know that
ultimately we're calculating two t
values and t is like the distance from
the origin along the right direction to
our actual hit point so clearly the
smallest t value the smallest solution
should be the closest hit so just by
looking at this math i mean assuming
that a is not negative we would always
assume that this is the smallest
solution because we're subtracting a
value from here and then dividing it by
2 times a now if we take a look at what
a is and how we calculate it we actually
use the dot product here of ray
direction with itself to get a
so
effectively what we're doing here is
squaring ray direction and then adding
them all together so there's no way that
can be negative so a is definitely
positive and then we're doing minus b
minus the square root so t1 is going to
be the smaller value no matter what it
might be negative possibly but it will
be the smallest value especially because
we obviously know that the discriminant
is going to be positive i mean it's
going to a square root and we're not
dealing with imaginary numbers so of
course it's going to be positive so t1
will be our closest hit point i might
rename it to just read closest t so
because of that let's get rid of this
other one we're not going to use it at
the moment and this is actually going to
be our hit point now what i could do at
the moment is just output the hit point
as a color so this is what i mean it's
so easy to do it's a vec3 it's going to
be roughly in that zero to one range
most of it will be because we're dealing
with a sphere that has a diameter of one
or a radius of 0.5 and since our colors
are also kind of in that zero to one
range we can just set our sphere color
here to be the hit point and if we run
this code we'll get something very
interesting so we actually get some
coloring here that appears to show that
our sphere actually does have some depth
to it and then we have a very large blue
section here because this part of the
sphere is actually going to have
negative hit point values because the
origin zero is here so therefore
everything left of that everything below
that is going to go into that negative
space from zero and we are clamping
negative values to just be zeros so
we're seeing this blue here because x
and y so up and down is our y axis left
and right is our x axis those are both
zero but z is going to be positive and z
is the blue color that we're visualizing
here so what's actually going on here if
you've never seen this kind of thing
before is we obviously have an x y and z
coordinate for every pixel that's the
hit point what we're doing is taking
those values and outputting them as the
color so the x coordinate becomes the
red channel the y coordinate becomes the
green channel and the z coordinate
becomes the blue channel and so we're
able to kind of visualize these numbers
as colors and see for example that the
top of the sphere here is green because
the y component of our head coordinate
is larger and over here towards the
right our x is larger because it's more
towards the right which contributes more
red to that final pixel this kind of
practice of outputting our data our
mathematical numbers as colors is very
very common in graphics programming so
that's all good we can see that our hit
points are working because we visualized
them hopefully you can see why it's so
helpful to do this in graphics
programming because the alternative
would be what like placing breakpoints
and kind of trying to look at this per
pixel or logging every color but we have
like i don't know a million pixels on
our screen it's so difficult for us to
kind of look at that information
presented to us in a per pixel basis and
make sure it's working across our image
there's just too much data to deal with
but if we can visualize it in some way
in the form of colors we can look at the
entire picture at once and see if it's
working correctly let's take a look at
this piece of paper that i have here if
it's facing the light it's very bright
if it's not facing the light i mean we
can still see it a little bit but it's
significantly darker as i rotate it to
face the light we see a much brighter
color and this of course works in three
dimensions doesn't matter if i orient it
so that it faces down it's still going
to get a lot darker and it obviously
works not just for flat surfaces but if
we have something like this my light
source is over here hopefully you can
see that the areas that are facing the
lights are obviously a lot brighter than
say this area over here which is facing
away from the light how can we take this
and recreate it with our sphere well
let's think about the different pieces
of our puzzle here what are our
different variables we have the light i
mean sure there are things like the
brightness of the light how big it is
all those other details but
fundamentally it's just the location or
the direction of the light and then also
the location of our model and possibly
more critically the direction that each
part of this model faces now we're
rendering things in terms of pixels so
we can translate this to say the
direction that each pixel
faces so we need the direction of the
light coming in on us and we would like
to know the direction that each pixel of
this model is facing because if we look
at this area over here we know that
because it's facing away from the light
it's facing that way the light is facing
that way it's not really facing the
light it is in fact darker so we have
this kind of observation here that the
more we face the light the more this
kind of area faces the light the
brighter it becomes so how do we apply
that to our sphere how can we determine
per pixel which way which direction it
is facing that is called a normal why is
it called a normal i mean it normal
sounds like a bit of a weird name for it
because a normal is a vector that is
perpendicular to a particular surface so
i have this pen here i have this flat
surface the normal would be a vector
facing up facing that way if i had this
kind of flat surface it was facing this
way the normal would be this vector over
here so in other words a normal is
exactly what we're looking for because
it's a vector that is facing the
direction that the face faces lots of
facing going on here so how can we work
out this normal vector for our sphere
well it's actually really really easy
since we know where our sphere's origin
is and we also know the position that we
hit the sphere at we can simply subtract
those two vectors we can take the hit
position and subtract it from that
center point from that origin and it
will give us our normal now we don't
exactly have a sphere origin at the
moment because it's just zero so that's
even easier it means that literally our
normal is our hit point with the only
exception being that we need to
normalize this normal if we want to be
correct the reason being that obviously
based on the origin of that sphere
itself those vectors are going to get
translated well anywhere in 3d space as
well as the radius of the sphere if if
the radius is bigger we're obviously
going to get a larger kind of vector and
that's not really a directional vector
anymore the length is going to be equal
to our radius so in this case it's going
to be 0.5 whereas we want to have a unit
vector that's actually why this image
that we looked at here was so dark
because we're not looking at these
colors between like zero and one they're
actually going from zero to point five
and hence whenever exceeding that kind
of 50
level of light so going back to our code
i'm going to type in glm vect3 normal
and it's going to be our hit point
normalized again usually we would
subtract our sphere origin from hit
point so we'd write hit point minus
sphere origin but we'll introduce that
later when we actually have the ability
to move our sphere around and probably
render more than one sphere as well that
would be nice so now that we have this
normal let's look at that instead let's
visualize our normals instead of
visualizing that hit position so there
we go much brighter effect so this is
something that you should get used to if
you don't quite understand why this
image looks like it does just take a
moment play around with it play around
with some other values potentially and
just make sure that you understand it
now the sphere is a little small so what
i'm actually going to do is move the
camera forward a little bit we've got
this ray origin at 2 which is the
location of our camera i'm just going to
push it one unit forward so that we get
a much larger image as you can see here
now because we're actually sending those
rays in the negative z direction the
normal that we're getting is positive z
which is why we're seeing so much blue
in this image that's a little bit
annoying though because clearly we're
losing a lot of that capacity to
visualize this normal here why because
the normal vector is a unit vector that
can be between negative one and one for
each component so because it goes down
all the way to negative one
we can't see anything past zero anything
that's below zero just becomes zero so
we're seeing no red at all and no green
at all for like this entire region here
what i would much prefer is having like
the colors being arranged that we can
all visibly see so in other words i'd
like it to be between zero and one
instead of negative one and one because
that way we can at least see everything
so how do we convert this from being
between negative 1 and 1 2 being between
0 and 1 well we can just multiply it by
0.5 and add 0.5 that will obviously take
that negative 1 make it negative 0.5 and
then add 0.5 to push it to 0. and
meanwhile our positive one which is the
other end of the extreme that will be
half to 0.5 and then we'll add back to
0.5 to bring it back up to 1. so no
change there so if we run this code
there we go this looks a lot better to
me because we can actually see the kind
of full spectrum of colors here we can
see that it gets more red as we look to
the right and more green as we look up
the blue mostly stays the same okay so
now that we've done this let's define
some sort of light direction and then we
can use the math to compare the two and
see the angle between them so what
should our light direction be well
looking at this image we know that we're
facing the negative z direction so i
think our light source should kind of be
also facing the negative z direction so
that we can actually kind of see it and
then maybe i want it to come from like
above over here so we want it to be
going in kind of the negative y
direction as well so that it's going
down from above and since my mouse
pointer is around here i want to come
from this side that's also basically
negative x because it's coming in from
positive x into kind of this negative x
space it's going left so what i could do
is simply just define like a directional
vector that's minus 1 minus 1 minus 1
because that's what i'm looking for and
then just normalize it and that'll take
it to be about roughly 0.7 it'll make it
a unit vector and more importantly it
will be in the right direction so let's
go ahead and do that i'm going to write
glm vect3 light direction is going to be
negative 1 negative 1 and negative 1 but
as i mentioned i want to also normalize
it so there we go there's our light
direction so since we determined earlier
that it's the direction of the normal
versus the direction of the light that
we're trying to compare and see how much
it faces the light so the angle that it
shares with the light we really just
need to figure out the angle between
these two but before we do that there's
also one little step that we need to not
forget about and that is the fact that
the light direction that we've defined
is a vector from the light to us
but we're going to be comparing this to
the normal which is a vector of where
this surface faces to so that's kind of
like two different things we have the
incoming directional vector and then we
have an outgoing one i'd like to compare
it to both be incoming or outgoing
outgoing makes more sense so in other
words i'd much rather have a vector from
us to the light instead of from the
light to us and that's really easy to do
i just need to negate the light
direction because that will obviously
just flip it and then once i have that i
can work out like the angle between
these two vectors and i can do that
using a vector dot product because the
cool thing about the dot product is it
will tell us the relationship between
two directional vectors in fact the dot
product of two unit vectors is the same
as the cosine of the angle between them
so what that means if we write this down
in our code is that this kind of dot
product between the normal and the
negative light direction since these are
both unit vectors is going to be the
same as the cosine of the angle between
them and since the cosine function of
course will give us a value between
negative one and one same with the dot
product it will also give us a value
between negative one and one and this
value will determine how much our face
our pixel on our sphere actually faces
the light source so for example what
happens if the dot product gives us zero
what if the result of our double product
is zero well then that would mean that
the cosine of our angle was also zero
and the cosine of 90 degrees is zero
therefore if our dot product returns
zero we know that the relationship
between those two vectors the angle
between them is going to be 90 degrees
that's actually perfect because if
something is facing 90 degrees away from
our light source so if this was facing
well 90 degrees like that you can see
it's it's pretty dark so really it's
just the angles above 90 degrees which
should get brighter and brighter until
it's really facing our light source
perfectly and that is what we're going
to use the dot product for this d here
is actually going to effectively be the
intensity of our color now obviously we
know that if that angle is going to be
greater than 90 degrees the dot product
will give us just like the cosine of an
angle that is greater than 90 will
actually be negative so because of that
what we're going to do is use glm max
the dot product and also zero this is
like a clamp but it's like it's only
clamping one side of it so i'm going to
clamp it between two numbers make sure
it's between two numbers just one so
we're making sure that it's gonna pick
the maximum of these two values since
zero is higher than a negative value if
this dot product is negative then we
will just get zero instead so now what
we can do is we can take our sphere
color we'll go back to our original pink
sphere color and we'll just multiply it
with this dot product and if we run that
code check this out how cool is that we
have our light source perfectly defined
in the place that we defined it at it's
facing the direction we wanted it to be
and we now have some rather beautiful
looking lighting hitting our sphere so
there you go
one small step towards photorealistic
rendering i hope that you guys enjoyed
this episode if you did please don't
forget to hit the like button as an
exercise try and add some controls to
this try and add something like to this
iron gui window that will let you
control the color of the sphere as well
as the direction of the light that kind
of stuff is really fun to play with and
since this is in fact rendering like in
six milliseconds rendering in real time
you'll be able to see that effect in
real time as you play with the values
which is gonna be really cool and will
hopefully help you understand this even
more and i really encourage you to play
with this code for yourself the code
will be uploaded to the github ray
tracing repository which will be linked
in the description below next time
we'll be talking about cameras how they
work and how we can have a camera system
defined inside our application here but
until then thank you guys for watching
don't forget to check out brilliant
using my link in description below and i
will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you